mein eindruck war der egal ob jetzt dass
der ortsvorsteher ist der
ortsbürgermeister der bürgermeister wie
die sind wie gelähmt wie gelähmt und das
und und komischerweise und ich möchte da
niemanden zu nahe treten wenn es ums
thema geld geht dann dann gibt es noch
mal extra lähmung aber ich muss auch
die bundeswehr macht das was ihr
befohlen deswegen habe man kann
aber die deutschen ja keine aufträge und
dann sagen haben die
feuerwehren gesagt unsere baustelle
könne da oben bleiben das ist keine
runter ich weiß das ist eine katastrophe
die hat bestimmt noch kann damit die
mannschaft von 1913 diese katastrophen
würden über sich nicht so verdoppelt bis
heute ist aber es war damals schon mal
darum wir sind heute aber auch jahre
weiter und heute 100 jahre weiter muss
das anders aber die leute haben kein
vertrauen mehr kein vertrauen mehr zu
aktionen wie deutschland hilft willigen
hunderte von mails vor und wo einer nach
dem andern schreibt wir haben auf diesen
scheiß keinen bock mehr und wenn ich das
so sagen darf ich bitte um
entschuldigung aber dieser ganze scheiß
der wird jetzt gerade bestätigt wir
haben die größte katastrophe der
nachkriegszeit wir haben eine aktion die
heißt deutschland hilft und was machen
die die machen mini mini mini mini wenn
wir heute das haus verlassen haben viele
den eindruck sie konnten über die dinge
sprechen was hier mit den behörden
überhaupt nicht möglich ist ja meiner
meinung nach verführt zu haben meine
große bitte ansehen oder die redaktion
oder an die zeitung
wiederholen sie das mit dem kreis der
heute hier sitzt
wir wiederholen mit dem kreistag hier
sitzt seit ich bin zu francos
organisiert was haben wir heute den
siebten september wir sind einfach
oktober wieder dort ja und julian
reichelt hat ihn angesprochen unseren
kollegen frank ochsner er hat im
anschluss an diesen stammtisch mit bild
chef julian reichelt gesprochen und hier
sein erster spontane eindruck von diesem
gespräch mit den betroffenen bürgern du
kommst jetzt hier gerade aus der alte
das benötigte am meisten ja der
leserstammtisch hier weiler war für mich
von allen leserstammtisch der
beeindruckendste aber ob der
bedrückendsten und der schockierende
geschichte die wir hier gehört haben was
nach acht wochen acht wochen nach der
steht wie immer noch alles nicht
geschehen das wasser alles fährt was
alles nicht funktioniert warum sich
niemand wundern was wahren geschichten
hat sich würden so reich ist an die
deutschen tun vorstellbar gehalten und
ich muss sagen das beschämt und wir
werden mit bild darüber berichten
besucher gewesen was du wirklich da am
meisten ist es praktisch die
hilflosigkeit der behörden
ja was nimmst du mit nach innen
220 sachen im camp wird und das ist die
art und weise wie menschen habe ich
nicht gelassen wird und die schilderung
dieser menschen sind so glaubwürdig wie
erschüttert und was mich berührt auf der
anderen seite ist der geist der hier
haus begeistert vom zusammenhalt der
geist von dann machen wir selber
begeistert und wir lassen
der geist von das leben geht weiter der
geist der ja und die gesellschaft darauf
so großartige weise und länger der geist
von dann machen wir es halt selber das
ist unser stichwort denn zwischen all
den tragischen momenten gab und gibt es
auch immer wieder
heldengeschichten jörg burkhart zum
beispiel hat eine ganz besondere
hilfsaktion gestartet und deshalb ist er
auch unser held des alltags und ist uns
jetzt live zugeschaltet hallo herr
burkhardt
sie haben es spenden gutscheine
entwickelt für fünf euro und konnten
damit helfen erzählen sie uns davon
braucht man das auf und wenn sie dann
fünf dauer auch das geld geht an die
entsprechenden
also auch
noch der spender ist aber das geld kommt
direkt aus dem giro und maden und
übertroffen haben nicht nur eine große
wieder erzählte unterstützung besonders
in
hamburg hat die verbindung ist etwas
schlecht ich hoffe unsere zuschauer
können sie verstehen wie viel geld ist
denn schon zusammengekommen und wie wird
das angenommen
angenommen ich habe hunderte von bank
sagte um verbrauchern für die erlösung
also mir liegt insgesamt im netzwerk mit
sicherheit setzt 100 danksagung für die
lösung und die resonanz ist also die
ganz geschafft das alles quatsch
gesoffen
belieben bei einigen häusern also
zuständig das heißt dass ihr
die über 10.000 euro liegen und haben
wir dass wir sogar überschritten und
hier wird dann das geld in den familien
aufgeteilt denn es gibt in meiner
familie die ich selber betreut auch
angehörige wo das gelte auch für
betroffene aufgeteilt wird super idee
wir sind sie das bekommen auch
die liebe dich gekommen das war ganz
einfach ich war in walsheim und habe
dort die patenschaft für ein haus
übernommen und habe dann gefragt was ist
das größte problem und das größte
problem war dass der handwerker bezahlt
werden musste und ich habe gefragt was
kostet der handwerker und sie haben
gesagt wir rechnen mit 500 euro im monat
und dann hab ich gesagt okay ich werde
es schaffen ein netzwerk von fünf von
hundert teilnehmern zu generieren die
fünf euro im monat spenden das werde ich
auf jeden fall schaffen und das haben
wir auch geschafft wir sind also weit
drüber wir sind ja mittlerweile in
meinem netzwerk bei
380 und diese fünf euro sind halt durch
diese 500 geteilt durch 100 entstanden
und so kam die fünf euro zusammen und
draufgekommen bin ich wie gesagt durch
zu samstag der geschichte und auch bald
boards heimgekommen bin ich durch marcus
biber führt und den willen die ja vor
ort als wunder männer so wie ich sie
bezeichnen vollgas geben tolle aktion
herr burkhardt wir haben es vorhin
gesehen sie waren gestern abend auch
beim bild stammtisch dabei wir haben
versprochen dass wir in einem monat
wieder da sein werden um zu schauen was
bis dahin passiert ist was sind ihre
hoffnungen
ja das kann man ganz einfach beantworten
also ich habe zwei hoffnungen die erste
große hoffnung geht an alle freiwilligen
helfer ich möchte nochmal erwähnen dass
durch den helfer shuttle am hubble ende
alles perfekt organisiert ist jeder der
sich irgendwie genötigt fühlt dort aktiv
zu werden findet dort im prinzip alles
vor was er braucht um aktiv helfen zu
können das ist dass erst das erste dass
das aartal bitte nicht vergessen wir von
den freiwilligen helfern und von denen
die noch hinfahren möchte das zweite ist
aber viel viel wichtiger das ist meine
bitte an die offiziellen behörden dass
ihr das endlich mal schaffen sich mit
den freiwilligen helfern vernünftig zu
koordinieren damit miteinander
gearbeitet wird und nicht gegeneinander
und letzte ganz ganz große hoffnung ist
und die ist jetzt wirklich knallhart die
ich jetzt raus gäbe ist dass die aktion
deutschland
und hilft die millionen von euros
eingesammelt hat endlich mal preis geht
wie sind diese millionen von euros an
die menschen die dringend auf hilfe
warten auch auszahlen wird denn die
menschen haben definitiv immer mehr das
vertrauen wenn wir so offiziellen
stellen verloren darüber lägen wir auf
hunderte von mitteilungen vor dass die
leute sagen weil dein geld direkt auf
dem girokonto der betroffenen menschen
landet sind wir bei dir und nicht bei
deutschland s oder anderen
organisationen den wir zurzeit nicht
mehr vertrauen vielen dank herr
burkhardt und wir sehen uns bestimmt
noch mal wieder und die sind heute unser
held des tages durch dank ihrer
spendenaktion mit den fünf euro
gutschein vielen vielen dank
[Musik]